- [Narrator] Watsonville, California
is an agricultural community.
We have 98% of our students are Latino
and about 90% of our
students speak Spanish
as their first language.
Teachers cannot do their job alone.
They need to have resources
because every class that they receive,
which is usually between 25 and 30,
has a variety of learners
in that classroom.
Teachers use a wide variety of tech tools
in their classrooms and Kahn
Academy is one of those tools,
'cause it allows for differentiation
amongst the learners.
- I want to subtract
four here, whatcha do?
(students respond)
- Miss Kotto takes teaching as a skill
and turns it into an art form.
- This year was amazing with LearnStorm.
I had a group of students
that couldn't add,
subtract, multiply, or divide fractions.
They avoided it at all costs.
But since it was an assignment,
they would try it and they would
eventually do much better.
And what was amazing was that
the lower-achieving students
were able to see that they
were part of something huge.
They were able to contribute,
and that, I thought, boosted
their self-confidence,
their self-esteem, and I didn't realize
that would happen after doing LearnStorm.
- LearnStorm really made me realize
how much you can grow in
just a short amount of time.
If you put that same amount of effort,
you can grow even more.
- I'm impressed.
Many of you guys are getting it right.
Some of you guys are getting stuck.
I will show you where
you're getting stuck,
and I love that you're not giving up.
- All of our classmates
work so well together,
and it really showed that
we really did win as a team.
It was really breathtaking
'cause I think our goal
was just to reach Level 12,
and then we ended up reaching Level 36.
We completed, I think, 8,080 assignments.
- First thing in the morning,
I had everybody start doing
some mastery challenges.
After I took roll I said, okay guys,
let's look at the progress tracker.
And it just kept going up.
The students loved it.
The growth mindset activities,
we watched one every
single week as a group,
and they would share their
ideas with their partners.
I can see towards the end of the year,
they don't give up.
They work harder.
- Keep going, keep growing
means to push your limits
and to, even if you make a mistake,
learn from them and keep
growing when you're learning.
- Thinking about LearnStorm
and the students going to college
almost makes me want to cry
because I think at the beginning,
so many of the students
felt I just can't do it.
But because they were
able to do LearnStorm
and their skills are so much higher now,
they know that they can
keep going and keep growing,
and nothing will stand in their way.